♪♪
-Let's get to the news!
President Biden returned
to the White House this morning
after spending the weekend at
his beach house in Delaware.
Things must be pretty rough
in Washington
if you think to yourself,
"You know what would be great?
The beach in November."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new pool,
61% of voters approve
of the bipartisan
infrastructure bill,
at least until Biden signs it.
Former President Barack Obama
spoke today at the U.N.
climate summit in Scotland
where he warned that
without immediate action
global temperatures could rise
by as much as two more buttons.
[ Laughter ]
The "Sesame Street" character
Big Bird
announced over the weekend
on social media
that he received
his coronavirus vaccine shot.
"We'll take him!"
said the Packers.
[ Laughter ]
Good graphic.
It's a good Photoshop.
You wait all day.
I don't see 'em --
I see 'em when you see 'em.
And I'm pretty happy about it.
You know?
According to a new report,
President Biden farted
while speaking to Britain's
Duchess Camilla Parker Bowles
at the U.N. climate summit,
which brings us to a segment
called, "How Is There
Not Video of This?!"
How's there not video of this?
Do you know what kind of
currency that clip would be
for monologue writers?
Think of how many times you've
seen his falling up the stairs.
Now imagine if instead of
falling up the stairs
he was tearin' ass
in front of a royal?
How's there not video of this?
I'd rather not even know
what happened...
than know what happened,
but I'll never see it.
Be like if you just heard about
that news reporter
stomping grapes.
[ Laughter ]
Well.
Maybe that'll cheer me up.
Can we just show that?
-Oh. Oh!
Oh! Ogh-ogh-ogh-ogh!
-Yeah.
Yeah, that helped.
-This has been "How Is There
Not Video of This?!"
-That's right.
Apparently, Britain's
Duchess Camilla Parker Bowles
hasn't been able
to stop talking about
how President Biden let out
a loud, long fart
when they spoke at last week's
U.N. climate summit.
To be fair, he warned her that
he was about to cut methane gas.
[ Laughter ]
Does that mean that's wor--
that she --
I just would have thought
a duchess would have
a different word than "fart."
Learn a new thing every day.
A couple in New Zealand
recently grew a potato
that was about 17 pounds
and named it Doug.
It's what many in New Zealand
are calling
"our top story tonight."
[ Laughter ]
Several inmates
at an Oklahoma jail
recently filed a federal lawsuit
that claims
they had been tortured
by being forced to listen
to the song "Baby Shark"
on repeat for hours.
So if you're wondering
whether we need prison reform,
I'd say we definitely...
♪ Do, do, do,
do-do-do-do-do-do ♪
♪ Do, do, do ♪
[ Laughter ]
Finally, today was
celebrity chef Gordon Ramsey's
55th birthday.
He spent the day
exactly the way he wanted to --
screaming at the person
who baked his cake!
♪♪
11 democratic senators
sent a letter
to President Biden yesterday,
calling on him to explore
options to lower gas prices,
which has to be so aggravating,
for a guy who's been hawking
Amtrak for 40 years.
[ As Biden ] Oh,
are gas prices too high?
God, I wish I had
an idea for you.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
filed paperwork yesterday
to run for reelection in 2022,
which, in Florida,
is just finishing the maze
on the back page of Highlights.
[ Laughter ]
The writer who wrote that
is from Florida.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't want anyone to think
that it's just like us global --
whatever, coastal elites.
Global elites.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Representative
Paul Gosar on Sunday
tweeted a digitally editade --
edited, excuse me --
animé-style video
that appeared to show him
attacking Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
and President Joe Biden.
You edited yourself
into an animé cartoon?
[ Laughter ]
You're like that kid
in elementary school
who insists he knows kung fu,
but legally isn't allowed
to show you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"My hands are registered
with the FBI, so..."
[ Laughter ]
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
jokingly threatened
actor Leonardo DiCaprio
yesterday on Twitter
after a video surfaced
showing DiCaprio talking
with Bezos' girlfriend
at a gala.
What a scandal!
DiCaprio was talking to a woman
over the age of 30?!
[ Laughter and oohs ]
West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin
is reportedly in talks
for a book deal.
Well, technically, someone else
will write the book,
then, he'll cut out
all the good parts.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
And that's budget comedy.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh, you came from budget comedy
and here it is.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
New York Mayor-elect Eric Adams
suggested that cryptocurrency
should be taught in schools.
Oh, no, are we going to end up
missing this guy?
[ Laughter ]
France's Catholic Church
announced yesterday
that it would financially
compensate sex abuse victims
by selling assets
or taking on loans,
which explains this new listing
on Zillow.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
[ Cheering ]
Looks very nice.
According to a new report,
a 39,000-ton pile
of unsold clothes
from fast fashion retailers
has accumulated
in the Chilean desert.
Now, all they have to do is
build four walls around it
and throw up a sign.
[ Laughter and applause ]
According --
According to a new study,
going to bed too early
or too late may disrupt
the body's natural rhythm
and increase the risk
of cardiovascular disease.
So, just to be safe, let's all
randomly change our clocks
twice a year for no reason.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Nike has filed for trademarks
for a new line
of virtual clothing.
It'll be the first
Nike clothing line
made entirely
by virtual children.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Now...
...when you guys didn't take
to the T.J.Maxx joke,
I had a feeling --
[ Laughter ]
I had a feeling this one was
going to be pretty bumpy, and...
[ Laughter ]
...called it.
And, finally, former
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
over the weekend wished his dog
Captain a happy fourth birthday
in a post on social media.
Unfortunately, Captain
unfollowed him a long time ago.
♪♪
According to a new report
from the Labor Department,
U.S. consumer prices are surging
more than they have in 30 years.
Okay, how much more bad news
is Biden going to get?
[ Laughter ]
At the end of the month,
we're going to find out
the turkey he pardoned was
at the Capitol on January 6th.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A federal judge ruled last night
that former President Trump
cannot shield
White House records
from the House Select Committee
investigating
January's Capitol attack.
Oh, he really wants to, though.
He's acting like a boyfriend
who just had his phone snatched
out of his hand.
"You don't have to hold it
to look at it!
[ Laughter ]
I will just show it to you,
but don't scroll!
[ Laughter ]
Uh, scrolling uses up battery!
During a visit
to the White House on Monday
to celebrate winning
the 2021 NBA Championship,
the Milwaukee Bucks
gave President Biden
a custom jersey
with the number 46 on the back
and he was really excited
because he thought it was
his approval rating.
[ Laughter ]
Twitter yesterday launched
its so-called
Twitter Blue subscription
service in the U.S.,
which will cost
around $3 per month
and allow users to undo tweets
before they post.
Or, for $6 per month,
you can get Twitter Gold,
and they'll just delete
your account entirely.
[ Laughter ]
After missing this week's game,
due to COVID,
Green Bay quarterback
Aaron Rodgers said,
in a new interview,
that he has had
"a lot of time for reflection
while in quarantine."
Unfortunately,
he does all his best thinking
in the shower
and, as you can see...
[ Laughter ]
Television host Dr. Oz is
reportedly considering running
for a senate seat
in Pennsylvania.
What? Who would ever want Dr. Oz
to be their senator?
The only thing crazier would be
wanting Dr. Oz to be
your doctor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was announced today
that actor Paul Rudd is
People magazine's
Sexiest Man Alive,
reclaiming the title
he first received
in 1938.
[ Laughter ]
A middle school history teacher
in California
was recently removed
after telling students
last month
that Donald Trump
was still president.
Though, for what it's worth,
I bet she's still telling people
she's a teacher.
[ Laughter ]
Rapper Kanye West's
clothing brand Yeezy
settled a lawsuit this week
with the state of California
over shipping delays
and agreed to pay
nearly $1 million,
or, as it's known at Yeezy,
a shirt.
[ Laughter ]
Finally,
according to a new survey,
40% of Americans said
that they strongly approve
of "Sesame Street's" Big Bird
announcing on social media
that he got
a coronavirus vaccine.
They were less comfortable,
though, with hearing
why Oscar needed
the hep C vaccine.
♪♪
President Biden is set on Monday
to sign the bipartisan
infrastructure bill into law,
provided they can get
Joe Manchin off of it.
[ Laughter ]
After New Hampshire
Governor Chris Sununu
announced this week that he will
not run next year for Senate,
Minority Leader Mitch McConnell
is reportedly upset
that Sununu did not give him
advance notice
or -- hear me out --
that's just how he looks.
[ Laughter ]
That photo was taken
at Six Flags.
[ Laughter ]
During their virtual summit
next week,
Chinese, President Xi Jinping
is reportedly expected
to invite President Biden to the
2022 Beijing Winter Olympics,
but, for his part,
Biden says he'll only go
if he qualifies.
[ Laughter ]
According a new poll,
76% of Americans said
that Facebook
makes society worse.
Said Zuckerberg, "Right,
but what do you think of Meta?"
[ Laughter ]
Apple CEO Tim Cook said,
in an interview this week,
that he's worried
about the amount of time
people spend "scrolling
mindlessly" on their devices,
which is kind of like hearing
that your weed dealer
is worried you sleep too much.
[ Laughter ]
The Canadian fast-food chain
Tim Hortons announced
a collaboration
with pop star Justin Bieber
to launch three new flavors
of doughnut holes.
When they first come out,
they'll be cute,
but then, they'll become
really annoying.
[ Laughter ]
Then, all of a sudden,
you'll be like, "Wait a minute.
Are these doughnut holes
actually good?"
[ Laughter ]
Before realizing you are
way too old to be enjoying them.
[ Laughter ]
A 105-year-old runner,
Julia "Hurricane" Hawkins,
recently set a world record
in the 100-meter dash
for her age group.
The new record is eight meters.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm totally fine
with your reaction.
[ Laughter ]
According to new reports,
reality star Kim Kardashian's
shapewear brand SKIMS'
collaboration
with the luxury
fashion brand Fendi
sold out in just one minute,
continuing the Kardashian
family trend
of immediately selling out.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today is
actor Leonardo DiCaprio's
47th birthday
and, when he blew out
the candles,
he was still Leonardo DiCaprio.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, I got my wish!"
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.
♪♪